all right so today I'm going to be
watching the trailer for Noah Darren
Aronofsky's new movie which means it's
probably gonna be the most depressing
take on Noah ever told all right let's
get ready to get the press people why
does this terrify what did he say he's
going to destroy the world the father
said that one day if man continued in
his ways the Creator would annihilate
this world and of effort he speaks to
you you must trust that he speaks in a
way that you can understand missile
water
death by water
a great Father's coming we build a
vessel to survive the storm the nog
this looks pretty [ __ ] cool what do
you want you don't know your king
there isn't anything for you here I have
made up my back you stand alone and he
find me you don't [ __ ] with Ray Winstone
Noah I'm not a bad guy
it's a little thing but I hates the
beginning
and they come that'll be desperate
that'll be many
pretty bad people see how hard this was
for you oh yeah
choose you no reason
that's the end of everything [ __ ]
our beautiful terror Mather's given away
the ending to many spoilers what if
you've never heard the Noah story but
anyway that foam looks pretty good it
looks like what I thought it would be
Darren Aronofsky's really dark take on
Noah I'm excited to see it I mean it
looks beautiful I think it's gonna be
epic I like the idea of putting a lot of
focus not so much on the flood but more
so on the story leading up to the flood
I think that's for the real human story
is that and I think that's really cool
plus I'm a Watsons in it and I would
bang her